folks we'll just get underway in just a
moment we have about a minute or so
we're going to give the clerk a moment
a work session
soon as it's 1001 i'm going to open the
work session on
senate bill 367.
it's now open and i will open the floor
for further discussion on the
bill as amended by the senate
as we had heard over the last um several
sessions we have been doing diligent
work to sort of clarify language around
the concept i'm going to take this off
for a moment
around the concept and
we did still have some underlying
questions i do myself regarding
some of the
potential emissions that exist with
fuels although they may not be
considered for potentially for
sale
as a but there may be an instance in
which fuels are used within the plants
and with that there are certain
chemicals that potentially are emitted
and i i
do think we have
the need for a little bit further
clarity on that
um and as well as again sort of with
um
sourcing of the feedstock and where
those feedstocks come from so with that
i'll open the floor for further
discussion
represent
representative contoir
thank you madam chair um just a quick
question and we discussed
how
i wanted to know the energy uses for
these plants and
it was said that it would probably be
through natural gas but i'm wondering
how much natural gas
would these plants be using
if they're at full capacity
miss grimalis
oh come on up to the front please thank
you so much
[Music]
for the record my name is jody grimbulus
and i am representing the american
chemistry council unfortunately i
wouldn't have that information because i
do not know at this point what size a
plant might be um so obviously its
energy needs will be based on the size
and capacity of that plant um
i apologize it would it depends on what
would be coming in okay um do you know
what the energy use decision is in the
other plants that are uh in other states
if they're using uh natural gas i can
find out okay thank you
representative stapleton
um
not so much a question but uh i have no
problem
with uh the conversion of these plastics
into fuel
the bill excludes the marketing
of fuels
but to be used for the process
and i'm referring to page four
line 20
uh relative to the reporting and the
mass of processed material used for fuel
etc
as one of the components of reporting it
goes to the department
just a moment are you speaking about
potentially other language that might be
out there for consideration
uh
this that's that's in my amendment i see
okay so we're catching the amendment we
hadn't really fully gotten to that that
point but i'm happy to open the floor to
that discussion if representative bixby
wants to speak to what's before us yeah
i i think it makes sense for me to just
go through uh what the amendment does
uh and i'm i will i will come circle
back to that but i think it just makes
sense to go through in in order
uh to point out what what's happening in
the amendment so
uh in
uh
section one uh the legislative purpose
and findings which by the way is not
legally binding it is just sort of
giving an introduction to what the bill
does
uh
and
but uh
the um
the the state the purpose the statement
of purpose uh first of all says this is
a nice thing which is you know kind of
advertising for the bill but more
importantly it points out that
plants that are
regulated under this
new statute this new set of statutes
would
be subject to all manufacturing
all manufacturing stat statutes and
rules that exist both in the state of
new hampshire and federally
and
we do have already have fairly extensive
state statutes that deal with
with
emissions and
effluents at
solid waste hazardous waste etc and
those are also
that's also encompassed by a number of
elements of the um epa rules on air
emissions water emissions hazardous
weights etc so uh this the
the purpose statement just sort of
clarifies that
uh that those will be in effect for this
for anybody who
wants to build one of these plants in in
new hampshire
so under the definition of advanced
recycling
the
[Music]
the key things here are that uh it
indicates that advanced recycling
is um
converted it basically does a chemical
conversion of
uh the
plastic feedstocks into uh usable
either raw materials and you
sort of further through the process
those raw materials would end up as a
combination of new plastics lubricants
coatings
uh and
it also uh says specifically that
the products of advanced recycling shall
not include hydrocarbons
which are marketed sold or used as fuel
for energy
now when it says the products of
advanced recycling the products indicate
what counts as having been recycled
so
uh it is within the realm of possibility
that a uh a factory would reuse some of
the
stuff that comes through the pyrolysis
process
as fuel to heat their pyro on their
pyrolysis reactor
and but
they would not be able to count you that
fuel use as recycling it would just it
would be essentially a
uh
part of the
[Music]
uh amount of material that came in that
did not qualify as having been recycled
uh and in any recycling process there is
always going to be some degree of waste
this would uh not strictly be waste but
it would essentially be in the same
fraction of non-qualified uh
uh
elements that uh would um
as waste so um and then that gets
clarified as as representative stapleton
noted towards the end of the bill
so
and then
the advanced recycling facility is
essentially
[Music]
essentially the same as it was in the
senate uh version
uh the
uh definition of um
certified
certified waste derived product is
essentially the same as it was in the
senate version of the
um
solid waste interchange a
depolymerization is uh
clarified to basically indicate that
uh the products of depolymerization are
essentially raw raw materials and
chemicals that could be used but
for
further use but the actual process
yields raw materials
gasification is similarly uh clarified
so that
it what gasification yields is raw
materials
and
post-use polymer
has been
modified slightly uh
and uh so
one of the things i realized in terms of
the way that post-use polymer was
used in the uh in the senate version
would have meant that uh
the
uh any any post you any post use polymer
like you know number one and two bottles
uh that ended up in mechanical recycling
would be excluded from the definition of
post-use polymer but in fact those
things really are post-use polymers so
we don't want to have something in
statute that's getting in the way of
existing mechanical recycling so um i uh
so
the the that's the the main it's the
main thing i i did was i added that uh
it would be it could be used as feed
sock for either mechanical or chemical
recycling uh in terms of it not being
mixed with solid or hazardous waste uh
the senate version said on site or in
process but uh because
uh we're
uh of there's a um another step added
that i'll get to in a little in a couple
minutes um
the
by the time the post-use polymer gets to
recycling facility it should by
definition not be mixed with waste or um
solid waste or hazardous waste so
uh and having a definition of post-use
polymer that doesn't include the on-site
part is important because we have the
aggregators who are that who are
producing that they need to be able to
produce it before it's on site
okay so the next section is the post use
post used polymer aggregator which is
a new addition which is response to some
of the information we got last week and
this is a facility that collects sorts
cleans
plastic waste suitable for advanced
recycling and provides the feedstock to
mechanical or advanced recycling
facilities
so this could be
and
uh that feedstock needs to meet the the
definition of post-use polymer and
i'm saying the department should make
rules about how exactly this is managed
uh one thing that i
see as a shortcoming of this whole
amendment is i haven't had a chance to
check back with
des to make sure that i've gotten the
language that's giving them their orders
correct so uh
so that and that's something that could
probably be dealt with in a floor
amendment if i managed to get to talk to
them this week
uh
so uh
what
in terms of what a post-use polymer
aggregator does it could could be or
does basically right now northeast
resource recovery um
does uh collects plastics for
um
for mechanical recycling and ships them
to
wherever you know there's a market for
them and gets the best price they can
they could be they could qualify as one
of these post-use polymer aggregators
and they could uh also collect plastics
with a
a wider range of of types of plastics
and provide them to advance recycling
facilities
the other is something like hannaford
uh where they bundle up a lot of their
film the filmly plastic and send that
down to the trex plant in
north carolina
they could uh get a permit from the des
and
then provide that filmy plastic to
to an advanced recycler in new hampshire
if there were one
did you have a question
i
i did um so on line 32 of that
potentially suggested language on page
two so it seems to me that there is a
wide range of facilities that could then
be considered these post-use aggregators
has
have a and you're naming potentially
grocers to
an independent
nonprofit
to many other facilities i guess my
question is
um
does that require some sort of
dual um
if you're having a grocer then be
considered an aggregator is there some
sort of
conflict with that or
i guess that's what i'm asking no uh
they should uh permits can be issued to
any um
to
to any um
operation
to uh
to to so basically this is just another
permit that des would oversee
and
uh there are many you know a lot most
companies
have
multiple permits that they are required
to have to that that oversee what the
various sorts of things they do
thank you representative
thank you madam chair representative uh
bixby um
when you talk about hannaford's
becoming a
post-use aggregator now would they have
to follow be under uh the solid waste
division because the aggregators have to
be registered with the department of
environmental services so would this be
something else that hannaford would have
to do
yes the anybody anybody who wanted to uh
sell directly to a recycling facility
would have to uh get this permit if
someone wanted to sell to a
if someone were to sell to an aggregator
so if hannaford didn't want to deal with
this themselves they could sell their
stuff to it to an aggregator who would
then take it who has a permit so that in
that case they wouldn't need to be
permitted
uh thank you ma'am chair and thank you
representative so um i see a conflict
kind of like with like when we talk
about a hannafords or something like
that um you know
that they would probably have to sell to
a post-use aggregator because
um i don't know if they want to get into
the business of solid waste
and
what would the cost be to them if they
had to do that
uh i do not know that is that is one of
the uh things that i have not had a
chance to talk to des about and um
so that's
that is one of the
things that would have to be dealt with
in a flora minute
representative kaplan
thanks for taking my question um
representative bixby i'm
i've got a question about uh
the definition of the um
in your amendment the definition of um
the advanced recycling
products
uh it says the recycled products
yeah i mean you said that this
definition indicates that
these new products that wouldn't be
recycled but i'm not sure i see it where
it says that how does it indicate that
these products would only be used for
and doesn't that leave wiggle room for
for the facility to
create products
that might suit their business model but
might not be considered recycling per se
uh i'm not quite sure where are you on
page one yeah page one
uh
for the purposes of this chapter the
products
will include monomers all you know
oligomers plastics
waxes lubricants and coatings and you
say that that indicates
that
these products would be
counted as recycling for them but
yes couldn't couldn't they then say well
we're creating products that
you know suit our business model but
just won't be counted as recycled
i think that
that is within the realm of possibility
i'm not sure to what extent we can uh
we would have the power to do that under
existing existing laws and i don't i
so i i'm not i i'd
so um i conceivably they could
um
although this list have here is a pretty
big laundry list so
uh that's pretty much everything that
would conceivably be coming out of a
pyrolysis reactor or gasification
reactor i i just have i also have
questions about the wording where it
says the for the purposes of this
chapter
uh i'm not sure why that's in there it
seems like
again it sort of gives them a
a loophole to run around and say well
it's you know we're doing this but it's
not for the purposes of this chapter per
se okay so the the phrase for the
purposes of this chapter is um
a
um
it essentially that that's a fairly
standard
way of
saying that and so so sometimes you
sometimes a word is used in law
that is has a fairly specific meaning
and
if you just go with the general miriam's
dictionary
meaning of that word you're going to get
you're going to come out with something
that doesn't make sense
and
for
or if you define something in one place
in law
and then you there's a completely
unrelated statute where you run into a
similar word
then uh that could create a conflict so
by putting in the phrase for the
purposes of this chapter it narrows the
scope of where that definition is going
to be um valid now it might be that we
need to
um
add that definition in if there are
going to be other
if there are going to be other chapters
that are going to be
um also governing
what's going on
advanced recycling we may need to
um
we may need to look at
uh
sort of in including the definition in
those other chapters as well but that's
something i need to need to find out
from des i don't know
uh if this is going to be sufficiently
global to cover what des needs to
regulate
but the the main idea is that this this
definition has to do with
this
specifically with the statute that is
going to be governing these uh these
operations
thank you did i see another hand river
than it comes why yes
uh thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative um
so on
going with uh what representative kaplan
was talking about on page one line
twenty
it says that um shall not include for
the purpose of the shelter
shall not include hydrocarbons which are
marketed sold or used as fuel energy so
they cannot
so if i go over here
on page four
and it talks about
cycling raids advanced shell report the
masses of polymer
in the mass process used for fuel for
the department
now
we've heard that some of these plants
are using fuel
uh
the recyclable fuel to help generate the
energy at their plants would this
prohibit that no it would not
that is the
so
specifically when it says the products
are
uh of advanced recycling
it's
the
it won't count as recycling
it comes it's a product of pyrolysis it
is not a product of
advanced recycling
representative stapleton
thank you madam chair
um
yeah that's a we appreciate that
clarification
but if any changes were going to be made
further i would recommend that
some specific wording be included that
the material could be used to fuel a
plant or the process to remove the
questions because we've already had a
couple of questions on that which you've
clarified
but to make the law clear to avoid
further discrepancy
a change to permit the use of the fuel
stocks for process and plant would be
helpful
i want to go back to
the aggregator for just a moment
we talked about the example of hannaford
you know with their plastic products and
wraps going to into the process
but why should they have to have a
permit
they're not drawing from outside other
stocks and they could sell to a licensed
aggregator
why would they need a permit if they
were going to sell to the license
aggregator we're putting a burden on
people with permitting every time
somebody handles a piece of plastic i
don't think that's appropriate so the
the idea here is that um the
uh whatever whatever
um
plastic gets considered post-use polymer
when it's delivered to the advanced
recycling plant needs to be
essentially certified as being a an
acceptable post-use polymer polymer not
mixed with trash etc so um
in order to uh in order to make sure
that anybody who is delivering to a post
use onto an advanced recycling facility
is in fact delivering the appropriate uh
essentially product of of the
materials recovery uh there needs to be
a permit in order to make sure that they
know uh what what they're doing and i i
would envision that this would not be a
particularly onerous or expensive
permitting process it's not
not on the same level as say you know
putting up a landfill or something it's
just making sure that whoever is doing
this has the
infrastructure capacity to do it
correctly right follow-up
you may follow up
all right that clarifies it so if if
hannaford or any other large
business or corporation is dealing
directly to the plant
then they need to be permitted so that
the type of material is is known and
certified
but you know there's a possibility that
there are third-party aggregators
in the market who are licensed and they
could do that clearance work if
hannaford was to sell to a third party
and then the third party aggregator then
goes directly to the plant is that an
optional case yes and in that case
hannaford would not need a permit
and they might decide that's the simpler
route to take
you
uh it looks like we're running a little
bit short um i just want to point out uh
representative bixby one second please
representative bolden yeah i was
actually just gonna ask um do we have a
kind of a deadline for this and i think
we need to exec this before 10 30 is
that correct should we
move through that or yes i i'd like to
just briefly uh take a moment among the
sub committee members only to sort of
have a brief discussion about where we
want to go with things
if you feel like we're
in the last five minutes going to
bump up against time i can recess this
at
30 after the chairman can open and
recess the other hearing and we could
finish our business quickly
but if let's see where we get to having
this discussion briefly among the
subcommittee members representative
bolden
uh thank you madam chair i i looked at
the amendment i still have a lot of um a
lot of questions and i received a lot of
emails on this bill and i tried to do
some independent research and most of
the actually all of the
information that i found about advanced
recycling was really from the industry i
didn't see a lot of um
independent science so i i
i think we really need to study this
further that's kind of the direction
that i would want to go personally
um
so i'm i wouldn't support the amendment
personally at this point
thank you representative stapleton
i'm perfectly comfortable it seems like
we split hairs here but i could see the
importance of making uh distinguish
between
recycling and the marketable materials
and
it looks like we've got it covered in
great detail i'm fully satisfied with
the way this amendment was constructed
thank you representative columbus thank
you madam chair
so
my thoughts are is that
i think um that advanced recycling um is
a positive
however
um
i don't know i guess my question is is
if we took a little bit more time and
just uh reintroduced this in a cleaner
form
um for it to come back
um
so i'm really torn
um just gonna throw that out there
representative kaplan
yeah i think we've gone a long way
towards crafting a good piece of
legislation uh given what we what we've
known so far and our time constraints um
the problem is i don't think we have had
enough time and
uh i don't think we've done the detailed
analysis that something like this really
uh really deserves i mean this might be
a good thing it might be a good thing
for our state's priorities in terms of
solid waste management
and and we want to balance that with the
interests of the business to have a fair
regulatory framework and you know i
understand that that's something that's
also a priority but we need to balance
those too and it's not an easy thing to
do
whenever we you know contemplate
something like a bottle bill or
composting or something like that we do
a detailed analysis a thorough analysis
before we move forward and i think
that's what we need to do with this so
i'm for interim first study thank you in
the interest of time i am going to
chairman put this in
this subcommittee work session into a
brief recess
and then i will have chairman pearl come
forward and do the things the chairman
pearl needs to do so
this uh
sb367 stands in recess for a few moments
thank you
thank you it is 10 30 so um i'm going to
quickly open
the um
house bill 368 and i'm going to
immediately put it into recess until 10
45.
so i will turn the floor back over to
you and give you 15 more minutes to wrap
up but we are going to have to be done
and moving by 10 45. i understand thank
you mr chair thank you
thank you and with that i will reopen
the hearing or the excuse me the
subcommittee works session on sb 367. it
is now open and i will defer to the
members of the solid waste subcommittee
representative contoir um
just
for interest i think that
the new
bill the new amendment drafted
by representative bixby
should be adopted because it does
clarify things further so i would make a
motion to adopt that amendment at this
time
i i have a question for the chair
yes it's just a procedural question um
if
if i wanted for example the subcommittee
in my opinion to adopt interim study
would i vote against the amendment
because i think if we adopt the
amendment we can't
representative contra
so
it's my understanding we can adopt the
amendment
and that way we can pass that but then
when we go further we can actually ask
for interim study but that way the
amendment is in the records
it would be my understanding but i'm not
positive we could defer to
representative pearl
oh
you're welcome to come to the yep thank
you
my apologies uh procedurally you
certainly could adopt the amendment and
then ask the committee recommendation to
be interim study i don't believe there's
a conflict there
additionally if you don't adopt the
amendment it can be reintroduced in the
executive session as well so
i don't believe there is a conflict in
that
okay to either way it moves forward is
that what you're saying thank you
i can withdraw my motion okay
so
we're back to the um
bill as amended by the senate
so with that is there i'm looking to
anybody if there's a motion representing
representative bolden i'll make a motion
uh to recommend that uh
sb367b interim study
is there a second
representative kaplan seconds
madame clerk will you call the rule
okay let's see
um
great
yes
um
representative
khan
representative stapleton
is this this is the vote on interim
study interim study no
representative johnson
representative bolden
yes
and representative kaplan
and madam chair the chair votes yes
okay so that's four to three
motion passes
with that the motion um for interim
study for sb 367 as amended by the
senate
um passes and we will
um close the meeting at this time
seeing that it's now 10 45 i'd like to
open the hearing for sb 368 and i'd like
to recognize representative pearl to
introduce uh to speak about the bill in
the amendment
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is representative howard pearl from
merrimack 26
and i am here today to speak to
introduce the non-germaine amendment
2022-16748 which is an amendment to
senate bill 368.
excuse me
so as we heard testimony on senate bill
368 originally we identified a concern
that the department and the commissioner
had brought before us
uh regarding the ability for individuals
to transfer animals without a health
certificate
even though it was
technically not legal to do so because
in 437
paragraph
5 now excuse me paragraph 6 under
current statute it says that no person
shall transfer without a health
certificate unless they have an
exception
but what's been happening is there was
no teeth to the to enforce the law there
was no penalty clause in 437-10
i don't know exactly the history of how
that was eliminated but it appears
originally 437.10 which is the penalty
portion says any pet vendor who
transfers live animals it doesn't
include anyone else who's not a pet
vendor so what this amendment does is uh
section one and two is the original bill
uh in 368 and section three
adds
the language in 437 10 which says any
person who transfers ownership of a live
dog cat or ferret without an official
certificate of transfor transfer
or any pet vendor and it
then makes them subject to a misdemeanor
and which is misdemeanor is in current
law for the pet vendors
and we will be adding the language on
the end
and may be subject to an administrative
fine levied by the commissioner not to
exceed one thousand dollars for each
violation
and additionally in
amendment 1674
section 4 and section 5 we had put the
new paragraph in in 437.8
saying no person firm corporation or
other entity she'll transfer ownership
of a dog cat or ferret without an
official health certificate
and the reason that section 5 is there
is because we had made a change last
year when we put the database bill
changing health certificate to official
certificate of transfer
so that's why you see duplicate language
in section 4 and 5 of the bill
of the amendment excuse me
but what we realized in conversation
since i drafted this amendment i've
spoken with the commissioner and
and with other members and we've figured
out that this was already currently in
statute in 437 8 section 6 or 7
depending on which version you're
looking at and that's that's where the
confusion comes in
because the database version moved it to
section 7 the original language statute
has it in section 6. so that that's why
you see it listed twice and that's where
some confusion was coming in and we
figured out through uh my conversations
with ols and with the commissioner that
we really don't need section four and
five because it's already in statute in
437.8
so what i've done is i've drafted a new
amendment
which is
amendment 17808
which i handed out to all of you today
which is the exact same amendment as the
original one except we eliminated
section 4 and 5 because we realized we
didn't need them so it cleans it up and
makes it
leaves the current statute in place
where it was already required for
anybody to have a health certificate
and this just
puts in a penalty phase in section three
action three of the bill so that anyone
who does violate the current statute now
is subject to the same thing that the
pet vendors have been subject to so it
basically levels the playing field for
every person who's transferring an
animal
so that's the uh
quick uh
description of what's happening in in
you know with this amendment and i'm
certainly
welcome to take any questions and
answer any further questions if i
haven't explained it thoroughly enough
thank you representative for taking a
question um
and you may not be able to answer this
and this may be for the commissioner but
even though everyone is legally required
to get a health certificate to transfer
an uh
you know one of these animals
most of the public is not educated in
that
what is going to be um what are we going
to be doing to educate the public so
that they're not subject to these fines
so with my i'll answer it the best i can
and if you want a further explanation
then i'll certainly the commissioner has
made himself available to answer and
i'll let him
answer that after if you'd like in my
conversations with the commissioner
this is an area where um that
it is currently in statute and
what they're looking to do is is have
some enforcement action if they feel
it's necessary
you know it's it says that they
they may be subject to an administrative
fine levied by the commissioner not to
exceed a thousand dollars for each
violation they're not going to go on any
any um heated hunt for
you giving your dog to your son any more
than they ever have been the statue is
going to remain the same the language is
the same on this
this just gives them some ability to
enforce what we already have in statute
are there any other questions
representative
seeing none
thank you i'm gonna turn mine back onto
so
the the individual button turn shows on
and off the other one mutes everybody
and i thank you for filling in
is there anyone else wishing to speak uh
regarding this amendment
nope
if not i will
close the public hearing on sb 368.
okay i'm going to uh open up an
executive session and since we're still
fresh on senate bill 368 we'll start
with that one we have two bills to exact
so we'll start with the senate bill 368
and
i will
move
senate bill 368 ought to pass and i will
offer
amendment uh
gonna make sure i got the right one
2022-17808
is there
is there a second
i will second that okay so we'll be
we have a motion and a second on
amendment 2022-17808
for senate bill 368. i'll recognize
myself to speak briefly
as i just explained in the hearing this
um
this cleaned up a loophole that was
in the original bill
there is one other piece that i
that we had changed in the original bill
but actually i guess i got to stay nope
it is in the amendment we also capped
the revolving fund at 75 000
my apologies i forgot to mention that in
my
earlier testimony on the amendment
so that
that's in section one line 17
and so this will only allow the
commissioner to draw
uh up to 75 000
a year out for the
uh for the hearing officer position and
we did that to address some concerns
that we had had from some folks that
they felt like they were
potentially
opening up a situation where
the department could go after new fines
with this hearing officer by you know
basically creating a bounty system and
this this will take care of that because
the feeds the fees that they currently
receive are far in excess of 75 000 so
there would be
no advantage for them to be chasing any
new ones
representative bixby
yes so what what we have before us now
seems to be a fairly simple and
straightforward bill that i hope we can
all support
uh
how we got here was not simple and
straightforward and i'd really like to
thank representative pearl for the hard
work he's done in terms of orchestrating
all the various ins and outs that got us
here
you're welcome any further comments from
the committee
representative stapleton
let's second that uh thought and a
motion i'm appreciative of the work that
was done and can fully support this bill
thank you
anyone else
all right seeing none i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role on ought to
pass on the amendment 1780h
representative lasalles
yes represent coumtois yes
representative khan
representative davis is not here
representative stapleton yes
representative johnson yes
representative spelaine
yes
representative sanborn yes
representative bixby yes
representative safakidas
yes represent bolden yes represent
dutchy yes represent murray yes
represent von plinsky yes represent
kaplan yes represent woods yes
mr chair yes
16 16 0 0 motion passes so with a 16-0
vote the amendment uh to senate bill 368
which is amendment one seven eight zero
h passes i also want to take a second
and thank the clerk because we have many
subs on the committee today and i know
it's difficult calling the rule with all
of the replacements so thank you
okay so uh we've passed the amendment i
want to move ought to pass as amended on
senate bill 368 with amendment 17808 do
we have a second
representative bixby seconds
i'll recognize myself to speak to it i
think we've pretty much covered all of
the
integral parts of this bill and what it
does and so i urge the whole committee
to support it anyone else like to offer
anything
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the rule on senate bill 368 otpa with
amendment 2022-17808
representative lasalle
yes represent
yes representative khan
representative stapleton yes represent
johnson
yes robin splain
yes represents sam bowen
yes represent bixby
yes representative sofikidas yes
represent bolden yes represent dutsy yes
representative murray
yes represent von plinsky yes
represent kaplan yes
represent woods yes
mr chair yes 16-0
the vote of 16-0 the
amendment uh excuse me senate bill 368
passes that's amended
i don't can we put this on consent
calendar
i think so because there's no
appropriation
i believe we can so
yeah
so without objection we'll put it on the
consent calendar
well thank you commissioner we
appreciate all of your work as well all
right thank you for what you do
okay we're going to move on to senate
bill 367 in just a minute i'll give
everybody a chance to
to get their paperwork in order
all right is everybody got everything in
order i think i do
all right so we're going to open the
exec session on senate bill 367 relative
to the regulatory status of advanced
recycling and manufacturing facilities
i'm going to move ought to pass and i
want to offer amendment well actually
i'm sorry hold on a minute i need to
retract that
i want to recognize representative
murray actually to bring forward the um
results from the subcommittee my
apologies i get ahead of myself that's
okay thank you chairman pearl so out of
this subcommittee there was a
recommendation of four to three for
interim study do i have that correct uh
madam clerk
on the vote
representative uh
the motion was four to three for interim
study correct that is correct thank you
and so i'd like to just say that while
the well
we believe that the concept definitely
has merit it is important that we move
forward with careful intention for
the next steps because this is a very
complex piece of legislation that we
feel
um
is important that we get right before
moving forward and so
that is the reason the subcommittee came
with the vote of
interim study on the bill as amended by
the senate thank you
thank you representative and i want to
certainly commend the subcommittee they
did a fantastic job and
a very thorough and
did a lot of due diligence in
looking at this issue
so uh representative murray is moving
interim study do we have a second
representative
dutsy all right so we have a motion and
a second uh i'll recognize
representative murray to speak to her
motion
yes thank you mr chair um so again i
don't think that there is any uh more
that i need to say i do feel that um we
do need to continue to look at the
varying
facets of of the bill and so for that
reason i am continuing with that motion
of interim study
thank you representative anyone else
that wants to speak uh representative
stapleton
thank you mr chair uh i was in the
minority vote on the recommendation for
interim study
and i continue to be um
opposed to that
i think we've sifted and augured this
bill as thoroughly as humanly possible
at the inception of this new technology
or emerging technology
and while there's a few items that might
be tweaked or corrected i think they're
minor enough in nature that we should go
ahead
with the bill
and uh we'll no doubt have some
amendments as years go by and
let's do it then when we can aggregate
it and make a better work of uh further
uh minor amendments interim study
is just delaying what we need
and there's no real reason for it this
bill is as thorough we've had expert
testimony
good inputs from industry and other
sources it's time to move the bill
forward so i would recommend vote no on
the
interim studies so that another
amendment could be made
further comments from the committee
representative dutsy
um yes i support the vote of uh interim
study and the reason is one of the
things
this is my fourth year on this committee
and one of the things we've always been
proud of is how thoroughly we've looked
at the language of a bill and how
thoroughly we have vetted it
for some of the new members that may not
be aware i mean we've spent two years
working on language to define the word
agriculture and to define the word soil
in a bill because we take our
legislative responsibilities very
seriously this is a bill with technology
that has far-reaching consequences for
our state
there are
so many
unanswered questions data-based
quantitative questions that we have
asked
the supposed experts who have not been
able to give us any information
on this and i'll just give you one
example one example
is that per their
information
one unit that they create will take care
of something like 12 000 pounds or 12
000 tons
of refuge
what's a unit
how big is a unit is a unit as much as
this room
how does 12
000 tons relate to the 35 million tons
of plastic that we create every year
this is database driven this is data
driven they cannot give us any answers
on this
so
going ahead and saying let's put this in
interim study we have a good record
in this committee of actually studying
bills that go into interim study to do
this for another year
i don't think is being unreasonable
thank you
any further
comments
i'm going to make one and
i again i appreciate the great work that
the subcommittee has done they've
brought a lot of information forward and
they they've got a tremendous amount of
information that helped me learn about a
process that i knew very little about
and uh
i certainly want to
give an awful lot of thanks to
representative bixby he's
he's not on the subcommittee but was
here for every subcommittee meeting and
has put it
done yeoman's work on developing a an
amendment that
that will uh take care of an awful lot
of the concerns and questions that this
committee has had and so i i'm going to
vote against the interim study motion
because i'd like the opportunity for
representative bixby to introduce his
amendment to the whole committee and i
think it will answer most of the
concerns that we the committee will have
and has raised throughout the
subcommittee's work so
any further comments
representative contour
thank you um so if we
vote against interim study then
representative bixby's amendment would
be brought forth um and then we would
still at least we would have that as a
recommendation is that correct
if we vote against against interim saudi
then representative bixby can introduce
his amendment that's correct
thank you
any further comments
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
a roll
represent representative lasalle
no
representative comptoin no
representative khan
representative stapleton no represent
johnson no representative spelaine no
representative samborn
representative bixby oh
representations yes represent bolden yes
represent dutsy
representative murray yes representative
von plinsky
represent kaplan
yes representative woods yes
oh mr chair no
sorry
um excuse me 11 to 9
motion passes
motion fails apologize so with 11 voting
no and nine voting yes then interim
study
fails
i would like to
make a motion to
ought to pass and i would like to offer
amendment number
2022-1
and i will second that motion
and i will actually recognize
representative bixby to speak to this
motion since it is his amendment
all right so um
in looking at the uh what we got from
the senate there were a
number of deficiencies which i have
strived to address uh i
and i will
um
say this with the caveat that some of
the changes in this bill have not been
run by des yet and i hope to do that
within the next week so that there may
be a floor amendment to
resolve a few minor things that have not
been entirely ironed out but i think
some of the key things that we that the
amendment does is in it adds a
findings and purpose section which does
not have the weight of law but it does
establish legislative intent
and
uh one of the and the key part of this
is that
it uh emphasizes that any advanced
recycling
facility would be
subject to all state and local state and
federal laws
having to do with clean air clean water
waste and land use
so uh these it's this bill does not
remove the um regula these facilities
from regulation it just makes sure that
they are regulated as manufacturers as
opposed to being solid waste facilities
uh this
the next change in the um that the
amendment makes is in the definition of
advanced recycling
and there was some concern that uh the
way that the
bill came to us from the senate they
could just be using these plants to turn
plastic into fuel
uh and so uh what uh
the the addition to uh what this
amendment does in that section is
clarify that for the purposes of this
chapter products of advanced recycling
shall not include
hydrocarbons which are marketed sold or
used as fuel for energy
uh just a clarifying thing there uh that
means that uh
if there's a use for fuel it would not
count as recycling so
a plant would be able to
use some of the product of pyrolysis for
example
as a way to fuel their reactors
but that would be
essentially in the same category as far
as recycling is concerned as product
process waste as opposed to
product produced
so it would not count towards their
recycling goals
um
are the
uh
there are i made uh some small changes
to uh the various process definitions of
various processes to uh clarify that uh
the what comes out of the various
processes that they list such as
pyrolysis
gasification depolarization
is essentially raw material it is not
a finished product uh the
uh after those processes happen there
needs to be further
uh refining uh or
distilling
to
isolate the specific materials that then
get used as raw materials for making
plastics those plastic plastics or
lubricants or waxes could be also made
within the facility but uh just the
the processes that break down the
plastic are different from the processes
that make new plastic is is the point of
making those changes
um
a
minor change to the definition of
post-use polymer uh
it
says that it's not mixed with solid
waste or hazardous waste uh the bill
as it came to us said on site or in the
process
but
because
we've added a section about post-use
polymer aggregators
then there needs to be a definition of
post-use polymer that is what that
aggregator produces and then the on-site
would uh part of that would be uh
essentially a conflict with the idea of
the aggregator uh the post-use polymer
aggregator is uh a
um
is basically some entity that
has a permit to collect
plastics and sort them clean them and
provide them in a ready-to-use form
to the advanced recycling facility or to
a mechanical
recycling facility
and and that
putting that
additional um
entity in there makes it possible to
specify at what point the plastic ceases
to be considered solid waste and starts
to be considered a
product that is
or a feedstock that is used by the
advanced recyclers so uh
once
the aggregator has processed the
plastics uh to the specifications of the
advanced recycler
they are then considered not solid waste
uh
the
[Music]
uh
and
that
uh in the definition of solid waste that
information is about what counts and
doesn't count as solid waste is is
clarified um
and
uh on the on page four
uh
there is a um as it came to this from
came to us from the senate there was
some language that had been approved by
des saying that they have the capacity
to go into a plant and make sure that um
the materials uh that are used as the
feedstock for advanced recycling are not
nuisance or do not
pose a threat to the environment uh i
have added
to that language which is uh similar to
the original bill in the
[Music]
senate which says the department may
inspect and enter any advanced recycling
facility to ensure compliance with all
applicable statutes
and departmental rules relative to air
water
waste and land use and taken for action
enforcement actions necessary
uh
it's i'm going to need i need to talk
with des to make sure that this is
actually aimed at the you know
is ends up in the correct
part of their their statutes but i want
to make sure that
they have authority under all of the
different uh regulatory authorities that
they have and for clean air or hazardous
waste etc to do any necessary
inspections it may be that this is uh in
fact already covered under those
statutes in which case
you that it might be amended out in a um
in a floor amendment but i need to check
with them to make sure exactly
i mean i need to make sure that they
will have all the authority under all
the applicable statutes to regulate
um
and
uh the
uh products of advanced recycling shall
not be considered waste derived products
or are
derive fuel that is something that um
those are it was in the original bill
and
uh the idea there is that uh
once uh once a plastic or another
material comes out of one of these
advanced recycling material facilities
it is essentially functioning as if it
is um
the same way that something was made
from uh other
um chemical sources would be so uh it
would not have any conflicts with feud
food use etc
um
and uh the
the senate um
had a phrase about advanced recycling
facilities shall um
i i think was something emphasized
uh using post-use polymers from
recovered feed stocks generated within
the state uh and we have strengthened
that to make it a priority rather than
just a suggestion
and
[Music]
then reporting for solid waste reduction
goals
this is something in terms of the exact
phrasing i need to check with the es uh
it might need some tweaking but uh the
key thing here is that uh there are
various things that come out of the
processes like pyrolysis or gasification
uh
and so um
if it's being done right then the
largest fraction of that roughly eighty
percent uh one hopes is um recycled
product which would be chemical which
would essentially be the the chemicals
that can then be turned into new
plastics it is conceivable that those
chemicals can be used as fuel and what
this section does is it makes sure that
no residual material
uh and no pro material used as um
used for fuel would count as part of the
recycling goals that would that would
count essentially in the waste category
uh
and
this and
then i also uh
requested made uh put in a
um
a paragraph which requires that all
wastes
produced by the facility be reported i
believe that's consistent with what the
epa requires but i think that we need to
have as much transparency transparency
as possible
to make sure that uh anything you know
any sorts of wastes whether um you know
emissions or
or hazardous material that gets shipped
for dealing with elsewhere
uh needs to be accounted for uh so um
that's basically what the amendment does
and i think that it adds some some real
uh strength to what we got from the
senate
thank you representative
and i appreciate all of your hard work
and your thorough explanation of the
changes in this amendment
any other comments from the committee
representative bolden
i think thank you mr chairman um i'm
definitely going to support the
amendment i think it
is a significant improvement to the
underlying bill um but i'm gonna oppose
the bill because i i don't think it's
ready for prime time i don't think it's
where it needs to be so that's kind of
my thought on it
thank you any other thoughts
representative murray i too would like
to echo that sentiment i believe that i
could support the amendment but i don't
know about the underlying bill
any further representative stapleton
i'm fully satisfied with the amendment
realizing there's some
minor points that may be uh added to it
or amended to it uh to make it a little
better we can always do that as we go
along from the floor amendment or onward
and i'm in full support of ot pea on the
bill and the amendment any further
comments
excuse me seeing none i will ask the
clerk to call the role on
the amendment 2022-176
representative lasalle
yes represent commtois yes
representative khan
representative stapleton yes
representative johnson yes
representative spelaine yes
represent sanborn yes
represent bixby yes representatives
yes represent bolden yes represent duty
yes represent murray yes represent von
plinsky yes represent kaplan yes
represent woods yes
mr chair yes
i didn't forget you this time thank you
16-0 motion passes
okay then
we have an
octopass as amended motion on 367 with
amendment 1764
h
and do i have a second
i'll second that representative bixby
seconds
and i will
recognize myself
and i will just say i again thank the
committee for all of their work on this
bill and i certainly want to echo the
sentiments that were brought up earlier
i believe it was by representative
duttsy about the due diligence of this
committee and the hard work that they
put into every bill and the thoughtful
uh conversations that we have and i
while we have some bills occasionally we
may not always come down on the same
side i appreciate the professionalism
and the courtesy that this committee
sets in a high bar as an example for the
rest of the house committees to follow
and we are regularly recognized for
our collegiality amongst our committee
and i i certainly appreciate that it's
the best committee to be the chair of i
will tell you
so
with that i would ask the committee to
to support the bill as amended i feel
like we've done a really good job and i
certainly again want to
show appreciation to representative
bixby for all of his hard work
representative conform thank you mr
chair
um as i stated before i'm really torn
about this bill although i think that
representative bixby has done a great
job
and i appreciate the fact that he's
going to continue to do more work on
this and bring another floor amendment
um to the the house floor which i hope
that if this does pass that everyone
would support
um i'm sure that it will be good um
having not read it i can't commit 100
um
so that's all i want to say thanks
thank you
further comments from the committee
representative stapleton
the world is a wash and plastic waste it
follows the oceans and
big areas of flotation close plastic
waste that they're trying to scoop up
and
it's a
gargantuan task
this process has been in effect we know
for at least 10 years not only in this
country but worldwide that technology is
developing
um
there there's a
aura of of care and concern on the part
of the manufacturers to make sure the
process is clean
and uh as little
effluent
in air and water as possible
and we're going to get better in the
technology let's start the ball rolling
and start to bite into the massive waste
plastic that we have
flooding over us and get this bill going
so i'm supporting
uh the ought to pass
further representative murray
thank you mr chair i also want to thank
everyone who worked on this um including
the chairman and for
the collective work that our body always
does
while the concept i agree representative
stapleton definitely has merit i will be
voting against the ought to pass as
amended motion
and i believe that new hampshire has had
a long-standing
and complicated history with pollution
affecting
everyone from our military to first
responders communities their water
sources soil and other natural resources
and this bill
is one that i
would want to make sure that we are are
very
clear in the source traceability of our
aggregated materials to ensure that our
state and the participants and
stakeholders aren't stuck
when it comes to materials that may be
deemed hazardous or have other trace
elements in it
and
so with that it should also be noted
that we currently don't have a materials
recovery facility in the state and i'm
unsure
at this point if the intersection of the
aggregation and murphs
might be conflicted in statute with one
another so i definitely
will be voting no but i thank everyone
who has worked on this because i do
think that um with the appropriate
amount of time we can get to a place
where all of my concerns and maybe those
of others would be ameliorated so i
thank you
thank you representative bolton
uh thank you mr chairman uh i'm also
gonna vote no i you know there's a
apparently there might be a floor
amendment and and uh if that's the case
i'll decide in the moment um but i can't
support what we have in front of us
today
representative dutzy
yeah i would just like to say that if we
could um
if we could have faith in corporations
to do the right thing then why do we
have thousands and thousands of
superfund sites all across the united
states where the taxpayers are cleaning
up from the pollution of corporations
who took their profits
went bankrupt and then left the public
to clean up the mess
further comments from the committee
all right seeing none i will ask the
clerk to call the roll on senate bill
367 otp a with amendment one seven six
four h
representative lasalle
yes
represent comptrois
yes representative khan
representative stapleton yes
representative johnson yes our principal
lane yes robin sanborn yes represent
bixby
yes represent sophocetus
no representative bolden no represent
dutsy no represent murray no represent
vamplinsky
represent kaplan no represent woods no
mr chair yes
nine
to seven
motion passes okay with a vote of 9-7
the otpa passes
we doing a minority report will there be
a minority report
representative murray will write the
minority i will take the majority blurb
okay hey that's our last bill
we've done it
[Laughter]
i want to really want to thank the
committee i really do i meant what i
said and we have an excellent committee
representative bixby did you yeah i'd
like to just um echo the
um
how you know i'm how proud i am of this
committee and how well we work together
uh
and i was wondering if uh i this i don't
i haven't talked to howard about this
alright yet so i'm i'm wondering if uh
we should we could have some something
like a uh
a uh committee picnic or something like
that and uh he has a really nice place
out loud and we maybe maybe could use
that
i feel like i just was
set up to offer my farm for a committee
picnic this summer
you were
uh would the committee like to do
something like that would people be in
favor of it over the summer i know we
kind of all have difficult schedules
myself included
as you know my day job is farming and
sometimes it is a challenge but we could
certainly look for a time if the
committee would like to entertain that
idea said
yes what sounds like a good idea even
the substitutes would like to
[Laughter]
yeah
all right so well what i'll do then
chairman yes go ahead as a a
child of a farm
might i suggest that you have this
picnic
at a time when you're bailing hay
and that you issue gloves and uh
and and make use of people it could be
like a uh
a working farm you know a picnic
i'll pass
well if it's going to be true to life
you won't get any gloves i'm sorry we we
just toughen up and deal with it so
anyway well now listen to i i appreciate
that we'll uh i'll send an email around
to the committee then and we'll look to
see if we can find a common time i know
it's going to be a challenge because we
do we do have a lot of vacation things
and folks do in the summer and i
certainly appreciate that but i i would
say probably a mid-july or early july
something like that might work on my end
i kind of have to fit it between the
seasons as we're rolling but
i will uh send something around and
perhaps we can all
you know give some feedback as to when
what availability would be on that
so beyond that i don't think we have
anything else unless pixby has any
forgotten anything
not at the moment there's another thing
that's kind of coming up but it won't be
until the fall is uh
a representative aaron and i are going
to be discussing with the folks at unh
uh about possibly a tour of the
greenhouses and woodman farm and uh
and the um
veterinary pathology lab
that's right
so there's one final thing we're going
to have happen here as a committee we
have um one of the groups that's in here
very regularly doing uh presenting
testimony on on bills and we certainly
appreciate all that do but the dog
owners of the granite state have
had a custom painting of our state dog
and angela if you want to come up and
angela ferrari is the uh
going to represent the dog owners of the
grand estate and she has a gift that she
wants to present to the full committee
and now uh i'll yield the floor to you
for a moment if you want to speak to it
thank you all i just wanted to
take this opportunity to provide this um
for all of the hard work that you all
have always done on behalf of the
animals and pet owners in new hampshire
i'll let
chairman pearl open this for you guys
sunday is also purebred dog day so we're
kind of aligned with that although we
didn't want to ask you to come in on
sunday
a few years ago
we did have
meet the breeds on the state lawn with
covid we haven't been able to do that
for a few years and we're hoping to get
that back up and running here in the
future but wanted to take this
opportunity to present a painting that
you would hopefully be able to hang here
in the room in honor of all your hard
work thank you very much
thank you it was a tape shot oh yeah
all right i had to peek at it
all right so
maybe i'll still get it up
okay with that uh if there's nothing
else from any of the committee members
i'm gonna let you all go home so uh
thank you and we'll adjourn for today
and again i appreciate the great work we
all do
you